You could become a full-time creator
staying offline the entire time. Here's
how to do it. Pick an evergreen platform
like YouTube or podcasting where you can
record everything just like this without
being on the internet at all. Then you
schedule that content over to those
platforms. Those platforms contain a
lead magnet that get to your email list.
Guess how you write those emails?
Offline. You can take your computer
outside or to the beach or whatever,
turn off the Wi-Fi, write those emails,
and then schedule those emails out.
Those emails should promote assets that
last forever, things like a paid
newsletter [music] which you could write
offline, or courses, community, anything
like that where you can promote your
email list too. Again, offline. So that
way you can create a ton of content
without actually having to kill your
brain scrolling dead platforms, and you
can make money while doing it.